حسنًا ، خلال فصل الصيف ،
تملأ بالونات الهواء الساخن السماء في كولورادو
في الطرق الخلفية لأمريكا ، وصلنا إلى
الطريق لمشاهدة أحد مهرجانات البالونات العديدة
هناك من أعلى
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير ومرحبًا بكم في
منطاد الهواء الساخن في الينابيع البخارية.
جميل هنا ، يمكنك رؤية
الممرات المائية للجبال وبالطبع
البالونات التي ألتقي بها مع Peg bilson
لمعرفة المزيد عن منطاد الهواء الساخن.
لديّ درجة البكالوريوس والماجستير في
هندسة الطيران ، لذلك كانت حياتي المهنية بأكملها عبارة
عن الطائرات أو
ربط الطيران وعائلتها تدعوني إلى  انضم
إليهم كجزء من طاقمها وهم
يضعونني في العمل. القاعدة الأولى في
نفخ البالون ، لا تلمس البالون
إلا أننا أشرنا إلى أننا نتخبط ،
نعم ، نبدأ هنا ، حسنًا ،
هذا أمر لا يصدق أن
نرى  داخل البالون ، لذلك عندما يتم
نفخنا سنكون بارتفاع ستة طوابق ،
هذا عبارة عن ستة طوابق من هنا إلى هنا
يتكون نظام البالون
من المغلف وهو
الجزء الجميل وهو البالون الذي
نسميها بشكل كلاسيكي ثم سلة
بها خزانات وقود ونظام موقد
لا توجد طريقة لطيفة للقيام بذلك ، فلا يوجد
كل الحق في حاجة إلى يد سواء كانت
مثالية
[موسيقى]
التحدي الأكبر الذي يطير منطادًا
هو أنه يمكنني التحكم فقط في الصعود أو
الهبوط  الذهاب لأعلى أو لأسفل
، وما يمكّنني من الذهاب في
اتجاهات مختلفة هو التنقل في
الرياح على ارتفاعات مختلفة ، pegg هي
أيضًا متسابق منطاد هواء ساخن تنافسي
، تُظهر لنا تقنية رائعة تسمى
الرش والاندفاعة حيث ترقص
على قمة الماء.  كم
هم جميلون ، يمكنك رؤية الانعكاسات في
الوقت الحالي ، تنعكس البالونات
في البحيرة هنا ، أليس هذا جميلًا ، إنه
رائع ، هدفنا كله هو إقامة
حدث مجتمعي حيث يمكننا أن نجعل
المجتمع سعيدًا ، هل ترى أيًا من هذه
الأشخاص الذين لم يبتسموا
هذا العام ، كان لدينا مغني أوبرا يغني
أو الأرض ،
لذا فإنني وزوجي أرى هذا حقًا
لأنه الهدية التي يجب أن
نقدمها كلها تطوعية وتبدو عائلتنا على أنها
عطلة  عندما نكون قادرين على القدوم إلى
هذه التجمعات المختلفة ، فهذه رحلة تخييم
إذا كان لديك أي فكرة للقيام
بذلك ، اغتنم
الفرصة الآن ، يمكنك أن تعفو عني
، فأنا جالس